deux policiers devant les juges cet
après midi les deux hommes sont accusés
d'avoir tiré bd sur une personne en
février dernier à paris à sept ans plus
qu'à sept affirmé christophe blessé au
menton pendant un rassemblement de gilet
jaune pour en parler on va tout de suite
retrouvé notre reporter katia pique
nique elle se trouve devant le tribunal
judiciaire de paris
[Musique]
bonjour katia alors qu'est ce qu'on
attend de ce procès aujourd'hui
et bien de déterminer si le gilet jaune
christophe m a bien été visés par des
tirs de l bd ce jour là et donc toucher
il avait été blessé au menton et à
l'abdomen le 3 février 2019 et en effet
ce jour là de nombreuses vidéos des
témoignages accréditent cette version
même si la préfecture n'a pas donné
suite aux questions de la fp qui
enquêtait justement sur cet incident en
tout cas ce jour là le jeune homme s'est
retrouvé couvert de sang le menton
ouvert il y aurait donc peut-être eu des
tirs de l bd à moins de 10 mètres des
tirs tendus ce qui est un usage
inapproprié de cette arme donc deux
policiers de 39 et 42 ans sont suspectés
d'avoir fait ces tirs ils seront jugés
pour violences aggravées ayant entraîné
une incapacité de plus de huit jours
alors casias est une énième polémique
sur l' usage du lb des dans les
manifestations
et oui en effet il ya eu un grand nombre
d' usage inapproprié de cette arme dans
les rassemblements donc en 2019 on avait
noté 19 fracture orbital et encore je ne
parle que de ce type de blessure à tel
point qu'en septembre 2020 gérald
darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur
avait annoncé que désormais chaque tir
de l bd serait supervisée afin de mieux
évaluer à la situation et la commission
d' enquête sur le maintien de l'ordre en
janvier avait préconisé d'interdire
cette arme
sauf dans des cas extrêmes afin d'éviter
les escalades et avant cela encore en
juillet dernier l'ancien défenseur des
droits jacques toubon avait aussi
recommandé d'interdire cet art mais il
faut aussi noter qu'en novembre dernier
bien pour la première fois l'état a été
condamné pour un tir de l bd sur une
manifestante lors d'un rassemblement de
gilet jaune
merci beaucoup katia pour toutes ces
précisions katia technique en direct
devant le tribunal judiciaire de paris
vous suivez pour nous ce procès donc de
deux policiers jugés pour avoir blessé
un gilet jaune